hi YouTube I'm so long Muhammad from
behind I just like to answer the devil's
question what is the one thing that
company's business lee governments and
individuals can do to make the world a
better place in 2008 thought about this
a law and really I think in this time of
uncertainty that we live being open to
one another is the biggest thing that we
could do to make this world a better
place by sharing ideas as we are doing
here by listening to one another and by
investing in new people technologies and
companies I believe we can do a long I
have heard some fantastic ideas
regarding climate change I heard some
fantastic ideas regarding energy
dependence and I have heard many
fantastic ideas for a walk that have
been shared communicated and transmitted
across the globe so while many in this
world today are calling for the closure
of borders the increase protection of
either products or people the world has
always been at its best when it has been
open to itself thank you very much